the planet we live on is full of life
and has been for billions of years
living things on earth have existed for
as long as they have because life found
a way to create life sounds crazy right
to put it another way living things
found ways to reproduce creating
offspring that can then go on to
reproduce themselves but what exactly is
reproduction
well reproduction is the process of
making new organisms this happens when
parent organisms reproduce to form
offspring during reproduction organisms
pass their genetic information onto
their offspring this genetic information
provides blueprints for how the
offspring will grow and develop and is
how traits get passed on from one
generation to the next there are two
main ways organisms on earth reproduce
this is through asexual reproduction or
sexual reproduction
let's start off by breaking down asexual
reproduction first
in asexual reproduction only one parent
is involved in producing offspring
due to this the offspring will inherit
all of their genes from that single
parent
this means that asexual reproduction
produces offspring that are genetically
identical to their parent or in other
words they have the same collection of
genes
various kinds of microorganisms plants
and even animals are able to reproduce
asexually
an example of asexual reproduction in
microorganisms can be seen in bacteria
this is due to their use of a specific
type of asexual reproduction called
binary fission
during this process a single bacterial
cell grows copies its genes and divides
into two identical cells kind of like a
copy machine plants are able to
reproduce asexually too for example some
plants grow their offspring off of
themselves
in fact in many succulents you can see
baby plants growing off of their parent
plant
these babies have the same genes as
their parent plant and can grow on their
own if you remove them and plant them in
soil
finally and interestingly there are
various animals that can reproduce
asexually one example is seen in
starfish or sea stars
some species of starfish can split into
multiple parts that then grow into new
starfish
and since they have the same genes each
new starfish is a clone of its original
now that we've covered a sexual
reproduction let's move on to sexual
reproduction
unlike asexual reproduction sexual
reproduction involves two parents
producing an offspring together instead
of one
this is important because it means that
the offspring will inherit half of their
genes from one parent and half of their
genes from the other
because of this asexual reproduction
produces offspring that are genetically
distinct or have a different combination
of genes compared to either parent
with this because of the way the genes
are passed on there are tons of
different combinations of genes that can
be received from the two parents in
other words this means that sexual
reproduction creates offspring that show
a lot of genetic variation between their
siblings to better understand this let's
take a look at my own dogs they're
brother and sister so they share the
same parents which i've drawn here as
you've probably noticed my dogs look
pretty different from each other one of
the most notable differences though is
how one of them received jeans from this
parent that gave them markings above
their eyes that kind of look like
eyebrows while the other did not and
while it's easy to spot genetic
differences like my dog's eyebrows
genetic variation goes way deeper than
dog's fur
it's what makes sexually reproduced
organisms genetically distinct from each
other and gives the building blocks to
who they are and with that you now know
the difference between asexual and
sexual reproduction let's do a quick
overview of what you've learned today
living organisms reproduce to create
offspring through either asexual or
sexual reproduction
asexual reproduction involves only one
parent meaning the parent and offspring
will have identical genes
sexual reproduction involves two parents
and results in offspring that are
genetically unique compared to either
parent
and this all goes to show how
fantastically unique life on earth is
though organisms may differ in the ways
that they've been able to reproduce as
seen in the examples between bacteria
succulents starfish and dogs
these organisms as with all living
things
share the ability to create more life
just as all life has shared for billions
of years here on this planet